Quand on pense
à la culture générale nécessaire
pour réussir les concours administratifs,
on imagine ça :
La culture générale,
c’est tellement GÉNÉRAL
qu’on ne sait pas
QUOI FAIRE,
ni COMMENT
le faire,
pour l’améliorer.
Mais dans dix minutes,
ça sera différent :
à la fin de cette vidéo,
TOUT sera clair
dans votre esprit.
L’enjeu de la culture générale
pour passer les concours administratifs,
je le connais bien,
parce que j’ai moi-même
préparé le concours de l’ENA
pendant deux ans
— mais surtout parce que,
chaque année,
je forme des personnes
qui préparent les concours administratifs
à la méthodologie de la dissertation.
Et du coup,
comme j’ai une obligation de résultat,
j’ai une perspective
TRÈS PRAGMATIQUE
sur la question.
Vous ne devez pas
améliorer votre culture générale
pour l’amour de la culture,
ni pour épater la galerie
— non,
vous devez améliorer
votre culture générale
POUR RÉUSSIR
les épreuves des concours administratifs,
et en particulier les dissertations.
Cette précision est importante,
parce que si votre objectif est vague,
vous ne saurez pas comment l’atteindre
et vous perdrez beaucoup de temps.
Donc souvenez-vous bien :
votre objectif précis,
c’est d’être capable de
DONNER L’IMPRESSION
que vous avez UNE BONNE
culture générale
aux épreuves des concours administratifs,
et en particulier en
dissertation.
C’est vrai que c’est important
dans cet exercice,
mais ce qui est crucial
pour le réussir,
ce ne sont pas les connaissances
— mais LA MÉTHODE.
Ça tombe bien :
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut !
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail
SIMPLE
et PRATIQUE
pour gagner RAPIDEMENT
des points en dissertation.
Les candidats aux concours administratifs
l’adorent,
donc inscrivez-vous
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Mais ne le découvrez pas
tout de suite
— comme c’est un cours par e-mail,
vous pourrez le découvrir après la vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Ne partez pas maintenant
parce que ce que je vais vous dire
est important :
je vais vous révéler
LES TROIS STRATES
de la culture générale nécessaire
pour réussir les concours administratifs,
puis je vais aussi vous donner
des solutions SIMPLES
et PRATIQUES
pour AMÉLIORER
ces trois strates.
Regardez ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo jusqu’au bout
et vous allez gagner ÉNORMÉMENT
de temps
dans votre préparation
des concours administratifs.
La PREMIÈRE STRATE
de la culture générale nécessaire
pour réussir les concours administratifs,
est LA PLUS LARGE.
Ce n’est pas
ce que vous avez besoin de connaître
pour réussir les quiz de culture générale
que vous pouvez trouver sur internet.
Non,
c’est le contenu culturel
que LE SYSTÈME ACADÉMIQUE FRANÇAIS
valorise EN PRIORITÉ.
Grosso modo,
ce sont L’HISTOIRE,
LA LITTÉRATURE
et LA PHILOSOPHIE.
Que les concours administratifs
demandent une culture historique,
une culture littéraire,
et une culture philosophique,
c’est cohérent
par rapport au système scolaire français,
parce que vous avez étudié
ces trois matières
au collège et au lycée.
Après,
j’imagine que,
comme beaucoup de candidats,
vos souvenirs ne sont
pas très frais…
Donc vous DEVEZ
faire quelque chose.
Mais tout d’abord,
que devez-vous ÉVITER
de faire ?
Il y a deux méthodes
DÉSASTREUSES.
La première,
c’est de lire les ouvrages de référence
un par un.
Si vos concours administratifs
sont dans dix ans,
pourquoi pas